good evening everybody
my name is philip howell i'm the chief
executive of Rathbones working in
partnership this evening once again with
The Spectator arguably we're in one of
the most complex and challenging
environments of our entire history and
hence our very valued partnership with
The Spectator and tonight they will help
us with this wonderful panel to untangle
the political dimension of that Rubik
cube let me just ask you with the show
of hands the question that we're asking
tonight is party politics broken who
believes that to be the case let me see
some hands and who thinks that the party
system is still broadly working Wow so
it's pretty much 50/50 on the morning of
June the 23rd both the British political
establishment and the British media
establishment thought we were voting to
remain and then the results came in and
what we saw as the night went on was
what I think is best described as an
English an English provincial peasants
revolt it is the biggest blow to date of
establishment politics of modern times
the Labour Party could not find a single
politician to be a credible messenger
about why you should stay in to the UK
working clock before you say anything
about the Tories I should tell you all
that Boris Johnson has just been
announced as the new foreign secretary
of the United Kingdom so I mean want to
know if I was telling a joke there last
year in the US we said that basically
things can't go on like this and they
didn't they got worse if we were
discussing is the British government
broken or is the economy broken or is
their lines broken I probably say yes
party politics I believed to be one of
the great inventions of the British
political system and it's not broken I
don't think it'll ever be broken and
this British democracy is broken and I
think it's a wonder to behold this
particular invention of the British
prodigals system is a work of genius
don't knock it support it Jamie's
probably born after 1980 1980 so this is
the least party loyal of the lot and
typically only only 20% of people of
James's generation or younger will say
that their party law and in 1983 only
one person in five in Britain said they
they trusted politicians to tell the
truth the figure in 2015 at the end of
2015
identical 19 percent of people it has
not collapsed we've never trusted them
our society is fracturing parties will
remake themselves possibly and there and
I think identity and values seem to now
becoming more important than economic
interest in this and that makes it all
the more unpredictable and who knows
what will happen next
can you see a role for more direct
democracy in our society more referendum
perhaps I think the elite having tried
it a bit may have gone off it
one of the consequences of breaks it
ironically has been to end austerity
policies in the eurozone we didn't see
that coming in this time of you know
globalization and jobs going overseas
and internet and insecurity and Isis and
so on that there's this harkening and
nostalgia for different times when
people felt more secure and so that a
lot of what's happening in the United
States is this insecurity is feeding a
nostalgia for something that really
doesn't exist anymore let's not have
another vote who still votes for his
party politics broken I knew things that
party politics is not broken
well the panel has changed views quite
substantially which I think only shows
the quality and strength of the panel we
brought for you tonight you have been a
most engaged audience I thank you all
for coming but before you go please give
our panel a wonderful run